new video reveals a more complicated
view of an encounter between Kentucky
High School students and a Native
American elder that triggered nationwide
outrage
the incident happened Friday afternoon
at the Lincoln Memorial in Washington
initial video posted on social media
appeared to show the group of boys
surrounding and taunting Native American
activists and military veteran Nathan
Phillips what we're learning there's
more to this than the first video showed
Gen propert is in Washington Jam good
morning good morning the students had
just participated in Friday's march for
life rally and they were waiting there
near the Lincoln Memorial
just as a rally for indigenous peoples
was wrapping up nearby now that first
video which took off online appeared to
show what people thought was the group
of students instigating some kind of
threatening encounter but new video
tells a different story this viral video
of high-school boys surrounding Native
American activist Nathan Phillips who
stoic Lee beat his drum caused outrage
but a different video surfaced Sunday it
showed what happened before the
encounter
you know what dirty crackers your day
coming your day coming when a radical
group of protesters caught a black
Hebrew Israelites taunted the boys for
more than an hour with racist and
homophobic abuse you could hear the
black Hebrew Israelites shouting things
racist things at the white people and
racist things and the white people
shouting racist things back at the black
Hebrews Phillips couldn't be specific
about what the boy shouted and so far no
video evidence has emerged supporting
his claims I took that Jonah is hitting
the job you know it was a call to prayer
I'll put myself in prayer and it was
Phillips who approached the boys not as
it first appeared the other way around
he walked among the group as they
appeared to chant to his drumbeats
Phillips said he believed he had to do
something to protect the black
Israelites group from the boys some of
whom wore make America great again hats
these students they're starting to get
this mob mentality and what did you see
that made you think that it was a mob
mentality well a hundred over a hundred
individuals and all of them just
hollering things out together a parent
of one of the students told CBS News the
boys were told not to engage and instead
we're doing high school chants student
Nick salmon said the boys did not shout
racial epithets Sandman was shown in the
first video standing close to Phillips
as Phillips continues to beat his drum
in a statement salmon says he never
interacted with Phillips to be honest I
was startled and confused as to why he
had approached me we'd already been
yelled at by another group of protesters
and when the second group approached I
was worried that a situation was getting
out of control
parent Jim Wilson said he tried to
defuse the situation they were a curious
of those men so I got in between those
men and the boys and pushed the boys
back eventually I could get eight or not
8 to 10 of the boys that knew me and I
said we need to get out of here now
school officials had issued an immediate
apology and said they'll take
appropriate action up to and including
expulsion that was of course before all
the other videos emerged parent says
students have received death threats
viana it shows this real world we live
in Jan of viral videos right and people
jumping to conclusions without knowing
the full story I'm not saying that once
we know the full story that these boys
are proven to be right or the Native
American is proven to be right but it
just it the lesson learned is gets taken
store antic it's never that's going
around right all the videos are
disturbing on all sides everything I see
just is very upsetting yeah restraint in
the moment and restraint in reacting to
the videos